a defined remembrance of one of the
darkest days in Philippine democracy
thousands took to the streets on
Wednesday to commemorate the day 50
years ago that the current president's
father declared martial law
it's surreal and at the same time
so of course enraging
raging my relatives have gone through
is in danger of being repeated now the
proclamation of Martial law is not the
late president Marcus ruled for 21 years
during which thousands of people were
victims of wrongful imprisonment torture
and extrajudicial killings he also
amassed an estimated 5 to 10 billion
dollars in ill-gotten wealth
activists hearsay these are proven facts
but his son now president Ferdinand
Bonbon Marcus Jr denies his father
imposed martial rule to stay in power
most people do not realize that the
communist rebels how close they came to
Manila and that's why it was necessary
to declare martial law
critics say the Marcus's have been on a
whitewashing campaign for years they
admit it has been a success but say they
intend to keep pushing back
the Battle Cry for many of the
demonstrators here for years has been
never again never again to Human Rights
atrocities never again to let another
Marcus lead the Philippines well the
first arguably and the second Clearly
Now impossible but what they're hoping
for is that their countrymen and women
will never forget
armed with a laptop and a scanner 19
year old Carl Patrick suyat and about 30
other Volunteers started archiving media
coverage from the first Marcus
presidency shortly after the younger
Marcus took office because DeMarco says
have this historical baggage I'm very
very sure that they have this lingering
motivation to extirpate any proof of
their crimes while this Marcos in just a
few short months since bombon Marcus won
the election a movie has been released
depicting the families retelling of the
1986 Uprising that ousted Marcos senior
and books have been labeled as
subversive signs together with the
proliferation of disinformation online
suya says that make his work more urgent
than ever
partner below Al Jazeera Manila